voters in Ohio voted Tuesday to approve
a ballot initiative that places a right
to an abortion into the state's
Constitution prob Advocates say the
measure will effectively make abortion
legal at any point in pregnancy the
initiative brought in millions in
spending with more than $18 million
being spent in favor of the pro-abortion
initiative with just 7 million being
spent in opposition since August 9th
according to NBC News the effort to put
abortion into the state constitution was
backed by the Ohio Democratic party the
ACLU of Ohio Planned Parenthood uh and
Ohio's Women's Alliance Martin hasell a
proponent proponent of partial birth
abortion gave $100,000 to Ohio
Physicians for Reproductive Rights a
political action committee that opposed
a republican back measure that would
have made it more difficult to amend the
state constitution has advocated for
passage of issue one